à Khalifa ce mot sonne à l'oreille comme
quelque chose de connu dans le jardin en
effet de nombreuses espèces d'aqualifa
sont cultivés comme une plante
ornementale dans les espaces verts du
monde entier
et bien l'île de la Réunion possède au
moins deux sous-espèces de califat
endémique
c'est un arbrisseau qui ne devient pas
très haut il peut atteindre 2 mètres
dans de bonnes conditions en sous-bois
mais se développe aussi sur les
escarpesments abruptes là il ne dépasse
guère à mètre 50 les feuilles sont
alternes et peuvent adopter diverses
formes taille et couleur
les feuilles peuvent être vers Unis
foncez ou clair ou vert à marger rouge
ouvert à nervure rouge ou rouge sur la
face inférieure mais dessous la nervure
est toujours proéminente et sert
d'ossature à la feuille
les minuscules fleurs mâles sont insérés
en groupe le long d'une tige surplombant
la plante et pouvant atteindre 20 cm
elle s'ouvre pratiquement toutes en même
temps nombreuses mais sans odeur sans
couleur sans se faire remarquer fine et
délicate
mais où sont les fleurs femelles
approchons-nous un peu plus
les voilà discrètement installés à la
base des épis de fleurs mâle des petites
fleurs femelles sont blotties dans des
chatons souvent solitaire elles
attendent postées sous les étamines que
les grains de pollen viennent jusqu'à
elles
le vent ou les minuscules insectes qui
pullulent ne manqueront pas à leurs
devoirs et participeront sans nul doute
à ce concert de la vie
ainsi les fines graines s'envoleront et
trouvons peut-être plus loin une petite
place pour germer